as the unions say they are awaiting more
information on ccsd's vaccine policy the
district itself has some changes on
standards for hiring substitute teachers
kate houston joins us live from the
newsroom with concerns from some of the
teachers of how this could impact
staffing shortages kate yes kirsten ccsd
has hundreds of open positions of all
kinds and as the district works to
implement a vaccine mandate for all
staff some teachers think this could
make matters worse the clark county
school district has 750 teacher
vacancies which is drastically
increasing the need for substitute
teachers our substitute teacher position
is one of our critical labor shortage
positions through november first the
district can hire emergency substitute
teachers with a license who only have a
high school diploma instead of the usual
60 college credits they will receive a
special license for one year i know some
of the other feedback is you know we're
lowering the standards it's really not
that in terms of ongoing it's really
just to help the districts to
staff up kindergarten teacher kristen
nigro now worries a mandate will only
push more educators away because how
does that benefit the kids
how is that going to teach our children
to be the next leaders of the united
states of america i get very concerned
about that because
a warm body does not mean a good
education now nigro and other educators
are pushing for more information on the
vaccine mandate from the district saying
jobs are on the line people want to know
what they need to prepare for and
whether that looks like if you know some
people are like well i guess i have to
get the vaccine now because i can't
afford to lose my job or if people are
thinking well i guess it's time for me
to resign and go to another state that
doesn't have this mandate
i asked the school district how many
staff members have resigned since the
vaccine mandate was announced they were
not able to immediately provide that
number for me back to you